this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this episode as jonathan is also a bit
of an alien franchise expert he's taking
a look at the iconic sci-fi weaponry of
aliens fire team elite ah all right here
we go i'd like to introduce you to a
close personal friend of mine
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
we're not off to a great start in my
view with
the hand cannons
this kramer 50. i think kramer is
possibly from one of the one of the
comics this is a desert eagle in space
big chunky thing firing 50 caliber
rounds i think the front end might even
be based on the modern light and desert
eagle with the compensator ports cut
into it i don't really know what all the
stuff going on at the front is meant to
do there's a weird looking kind of
monopod strap thing that looks like it
should fold down from the front of the
gun that doesn't get used but for me the
whole concept of a large caliber handgun
for the alien universe is a bit of an
odd one if you're gonna have pistols
they may as well be large caliber so
you're doing damage to what as far as we
can tell are some pretty tough
uh alien creatures but i'm not sure why
you'd bother with a handgun at all
really just carry more pulse rifle
ammunition i guess the major drawback of
relying on a pistol if we're imagining
combating these acid-blooded deadly
creatures is that the amount of spray
that you're going to experience fighting
at close range with a large caliber
pistol would be significant it always
struck me that once aliens become
endemic to the galaxy which is where it
always goes with this franchise you're
not going to go into combat with
essentially the same gear that you had
in the original movie you're going to
invent some kind of new armor that's
acid resistant at least some sort of
face plate to protect you from the
flying acid in design terms and trying
to make this make sense which of course
what we do
for fun riffs on all the same stuff we
saw in the movie makes very little sense
with that amount of time elapsed knowing
you're going to go up against these
things so not a fan of the pistols
really
so the first uh legacy weapon design you
might call it except it's not really
because this whole game is from my point
of view quite a successful visual reboot
the weapons you think you recognize
from the original movie and perhaps from
other media are actually substantially
different and i've no real problem with
that here we have the smart gun but it's
been so evolved there's actually no
longer an mg42 with some motorbike parts
attached to it the motorbike parts are
still there the swing arm from the
suspension is there the motorcycle grip
and brake or clutch lever is still there
even the sort of barrel casing of the 42
is sort of there but every detail has
been changed i like the redesign i
didn't think i'd say that it handles
really well in terms of the auto
tracking i like the fact that it's
somewhat capable hip fired using the
stabilizing rig that we all know and
love we've got a slightly awkward reload
for this thing we're kind of reaching
past ourselves to obtain the magazine
and then back across to fit it imagining
that these are real for a moment that
seems like a slightly awkward way to be
reloading i'd expect some system to take
advantage of the stabilizing rig so you
would lock it into position so that you
can reach for it and attach with both
hands something like that we don't see
that in the movie but this is meant to
be further on in time overall i'm a fan
of it
[Music]
this was a head scratcher for me i fully
expected to come across an ithaca m37 as
a homage
and his family heirloom i'd like to keep
this handy
what's weird is including a normal m37
calling it an a3 implying that it's
somehow advanced but actually it's just
an m37 the only thing that makes it
sci-fi is the colonial marines logo
embossed on the side of the receiver so
you can trick this thing out to make it
look more appropriate different muzzle
devices and stuff different sights but
at the end of the day it's still an
early 20th century pump action shotgun
doesn't make a lot of sense in this game
as is typical with video game shotguns
this thing's pretty devastating the
slight confusion for me there is the
whole idea of hicks's heirloom shotgun
being effective is that he shoves it in
the mouth of the alien warrior that he
kills with it
i kind of assumed these things were were
tough enough that you needed your 10
millimeter armor-piercing explosive
caseless to actually do damage to them
maybe that's just me again it's a
weirdly old-fashioned
gun for a game like this
right minor bone to pick here in that
the whole point of the pulse rifle or
rather the assault rifle which is all
the pulse rifle is as a futuristic
assault rifle was to make obsolete the
submachine gun and that is what we've
seen and we look at the design of this
and it really is just a pistol caliber
pulse rifle it's just it seems like a
redundant weapon class
as it was in things like advanced
warfare um i'm not picking on this game
in particular clearly inspired by the
likes of the ump something in common
with the pulse rifle the buttstock looks
like it ought to fold or slide or both i
guess you pinch those buttons and slide
it but there isn't really room in there
i think we might have a little bit of
style over substance in that another
feature carried over from the pulse
rifle is the infamous digital led
readout for ammunition this reading is
reading 48 on the side but weirdly and i
guess it's because of the reference
object that they used to model this
thing the actual magazine has
conventional witness holes in the back
of the mag which i think say 24 so the
magazine only goes up to 24. a little
bit of a discrepancy there and i suppose
we have to question the original design
concept of why on earth you have a
counter on the side of the gun because
we know the answer is for the audience
so they can see the drama of the rounds
counting down so in a game it doesn't
actually serve that purpose really at
all
don't lock up
way more than i expected
i'd like to introduce you to a close
personal friend of mine or at least
something that's normally on display in
the museum this is a
screen used prop close as a real pulse
rifle as you're going to get in reality
and as
represented by the pile of guns behind
me this was a welded together
combination
of a thompson a remington 870 chopped
right down and concealed within a sparse
12 heat shield and cut down pump grip
now this one this is one of um i think
seven in the movie aliens um they were
all but two taken apart and then several
put back together for the filming of
alien 3. so this is not in its original
aliens configuration it's as it would
have finished a hard life of production
in both that film and alien 3 which is
why it has this plastic it's vacuum
formed casing that disguises all those
different bits this one was not a
grenade launcher capable version which
is just as well for my arm muscles
because
the dual units as they're sometimes
called were extremely heavy far heavier
than you'd expect some futuristic
assault rifle grenade launcher
combination to ever be the whole point
of all this was to be able to produce
muzzle flash to get the actors engaged
and reacting to shooting wouldn't have
been essential for a sci-fi movie but
james cameron as well as being a bit of
a gun geek like me he wanted something
that looked and felt real it was a bit
like the blade runner thing of having a
blaster not a laser gun so originally it
was meant to be an mp5 and actually
looking at this fire team version of the
pulse rifle i do see shades of the
original james cameron concept art i'd
be very surprised if that wasn't partly
deliberate i gotta say i do like this
visual reboot if you're gonna change
things up as virtually all of the games
have in one way or another you may as
well go back to the concept and come up
with your own version especially if
you're setting it in the future of that
universe i don't quite know how the
stock is supposed to function they never
use the stocks in the movie they never
extend them they never use the sights
either now there were no sights there
was just the groove for modern game we
need some sort of upgradeable system so
the optics they've designed for the game
are at least original designs they're
not just acogs and neotex as we've seen
in some games where they just slap them
on regardless of the era or context but
there's a similar size shape
an apparent technology level we're
talking 200 years in the future guys i'd
expect to see literally just a clear
block and the reticle should just appear
in front of you or if you remember the
original movie they actually had
eyepieces that would flip down the iron
sights are
actually depicted you can see them why
we have iron sights 200 years in the
future is an open question the glaring
elephant in the room is the complete
lack of a grenade launcher they've
removed it entirely from this absolutely
classic
um a bit of sci-fi history here i'm a
little bit heartbroken about it
so that's really my only
bug bear with this i'm perfectly happy
with what they've done to make it an a2
they've kept a version of like the
thompson cocking handle that's fine this
version of the weapon has the counter on
it which is nice capped off at 60 rounds
i'm guessing because they didn't want to
tread on the toes of the smart gun now a
big aspect of this that they absolutely
have nailed is are the sound effects
that rising falling tone unique to that
weapon might not make any technical
sense
but it just sounds incredibly cool and
it instantly
links you back to the movie
so the actual gameplay of the pulse
rifle is great until the moment you
realize you haven't got any grenades
only hand grenades
watch the sides
[Music]
we're looking here at the burst rifle
the several variants or derivatives of
the pulse rifle are a little curious of
course we already have rifles capable of
semi-automatic three-round burst and
automatic fire we've had those for
decades so why you would need three
completely distinct weapons other than
purely for variety in the game for me
there's too much variety scent might
sound silly literally the pulse rifle
would do the job of all three the burst
rifle the semi-auto rifle and itself
and that of the submachine gun but then
you would you know you'd have to do
basically make a different game
[Music]
so here's the other major variant or
derivative maybe in this case of the
pulse rifle it's substantially different
it's got a length and receiver it's
meant to be perhaps a higher caliber the
barrel barrel shroud is huge which i
guess kind of implies the higher caliber
that i think this is unlike a lot of the
other weapons in the game i do think
this fills a gap semi-automatic powerful
scope that isn't really functional
because it's third person but it
improves the inherent accuracy of the
weapon so yeah i i like this better than
the burst rifle this actually does look
like a dmr that could live in the aliens
universe
[Music]
huh
right this is one i'm not familiar with
it looks the part it looks like a
futuristic shotgun which is clearly what
it is until you see it in use and it's
literally a break open double-barreled
shotgun i'm not sure about it fitting
from from an alien's perspective
apparently made by the hyperdyne company
which is a james cameron reference to
his own cyber dying company from
terminator and in universe they made the
synthetics so apparently they also make
weapons perfectly happy with the look of
the thing it's something different to
the standard colonial marine stuff it
does make it extra pointless having an
ithaca in the game i must admit and the
whole idea of future technology relying
on a break open shotgun is just a little
bit
silly
[Music]
[Music]
right so they had to have a flamethrower
or an incinerator unit of course they
did it's uh
absolutely iconic to not only aliens but
alien they chose not to replicate the
weird-looking thing with an m16 carry
handle on it from the original movie
with the vertical fuel tank they went
their own route and i think i approve of
that they've made it effectively a heavy
weapon something that the demolisher the
smart gunner uses and it mounts to the
same rig so that kind of makes sense the
only bit that doesn't make sense is that
the fuel tank is about the same size so
they're not taking advantage of the sort
of load-bearing ability
of that harness we've talked a bit about
flamethrowers before on on the series i
think this one's fine there's a residual
burn going on from the fuel of course
that causes you an immediate problem of
you're not just getting attacked by an
alien you're getting attacked by an
alien on fire i might have expected it
to be a bit more capable than it is as a
heavy weapon i think the smart gun is a
lot more effective little detail there
written on the side read manual before
operating might seem like a joke it's
not modern firearms in the states are
legally required to have that mark
somewhere on them or at least in the kit
that you receive so you'll see that on a
lot of
lots of weapons
[Music]
okay this is interesting i buy this as
part of the universe
maybe more the dark horse comics
universe than the movies sort of a
bullpup
riot shotgun rapid fire compact close
quarters perfectly fine bit of weapon
variety uh no buttstock though she's
curious you know something with that
amount of recoil why wouldn't you have
about stock on it in fact i might argue
that that should have been a bigger
heavier weapon mounted to the smart gun
rig but that's not my uh not my place to
say really
[Music]
now this one i think is a is well worth
the addition there are various rocket
type weapons in the alien universe the
wider universe never shown in the movies
and the idea of a effectively
miniaturized man portable rocket
launcher thing makes a lot of sense the
fact that they've integrated it into the
whole smart gun ring also makes sense
although recoil with a weapon like that
isn't in theory not a problem it's the
back blast you want to worry about this
is some kind of a sci-fi system that we
don't understand firing sort of
miniature rockets using some kind of
operating system that hasn't been
invented yet so i give it a free pass on
that looks suitably chunky and
industrial and you've got to have that
ranged firepower for no doubt haven't
got there yet but later in the game
this is a bit of a weird one i kind of
feeling that the word flechette here is
being used for coolness factor hardly
the first time in sci-fi that a bit of
technobabble has been used without
consideration for what it means the way
the thing is firing the this sort of
pseudo tracer effect
what we can see of it operating i'm not
seeing what's fluchette about it for
those of you don't know a flechette is a
little steel or tungsten dart and the
idea is it travels at very high velocity
flat trajectory very accurate basically
a failed
attempt at a future weapon from what was
attempted in the 50s and 60s again in
the 80s it's deader than corduroy at
this point whereas the caseless system
that the other weapons are supposed to
use hasn't entirely gone away could
still come back remains to be seen but
flechette's not happening and doesn't
really add any value here it's really
just a submachine gun we've also got
those weird witness holes on the
magazine they get all the way to the
bottom and there's no space there for
any kind of spring to be pushing rounds
up maybe they've come up with some new
way of feeding from magazines don't know
x-43 implies this is some sort of
experimental weapon i'm not seeing it
being super extra effective so i was
looking for a submachine gun from this
game to justify its existence so a
bullet firing submachine gun why bother
you've got
a pulse rifle a flechette firing one i
thought that might add some value not
really seeing it from this clip
right thanks guys for watching the
weapons of aliens fire team elite i've
been cautiously awaiting this one and
have been enjoying it but as you see i
have as always i've got some views
thank you very much for watching we do
this regularly um over at royal
armouries channel we've also got our own
firearms related and other arms and
armor content as well links in the
description as always for donations if
you if you feel moved to do so and
importantly we have a whole mini
documentary on this wonderful object
in the gamespot playlist the loadout
series so do go and check that out
because you get you get more detail from
me and dave about this bit of sci-fi
history
[Music]
you